[Music]
hello
you're welcome we stand here today to
remember to honor and to lay to rest we
did not think it would happen in the
early parts of December but when can you
ever predict a funeral Brian do you have
any words for the 2019 2020 Philadelphia
Eagles after losing to the dolphin tank
you know we started out so so well we
had such high hopes and to end here to
get to this point there's never the
right time you know usually at these
points we say that we fought the good
fight mmm
okay say that today kid we did not fight
the good fight no we did not give our
best effort
it hurts at us hurts deep down on the
inside to all the Eagles fans out there
we grieve together and just know just
isn't right just know one thing man I
[ __ ] suck damn damn come on man
37 points arrived fitzpatrick the
Dolphins the 2 and 9 dolphins I there's
a there's a there's a title here that by
the way are the Eagles officially dead
no that was our funeral but they are
dead no they're dead they're dead
they're done they're done nail in the
coffin yes coffins nailed like also [ __ ]
you cowboy he's forgiving us huh my god
I got my hope up they lose on
Thanksgiving you hope it's way up I'm
like we're gonna win a division we're
gonna go smoke the dolphin I hope that
what I'm about to say gets thrown into
my face weeks from now if the Eagles win
the division okay the Eagles are dead
it's over the season is done thanks for
coming out
pushing your chairs tip your waitresses
don't forget you check to bag get the
hell out of here I hope that gets thrown
in my face I hope so too
but it's not there's an article here in
a local Miami paper which is dolphins
topple Eagles lose chance to move up to
number three in the NFL Draft we lost to
a team that is upset that we we hurt
their chances to tank it for tua or
Barrow for Barrow well you also have to
remember when we look at the standings
of records right now that team that was
tanking that gave up their left tackle
we're a bunch of pics there there are
only two games behind us that's it we
only we've only won two more games in
that football team the Eagles have the
same record as Jameis Winston Wow the
Eagles are Nova Machine have a worse
record than the failing Chicago Bears
unbelievable and so many people thought
mr. Biscay myself included worst
quarterback ever in Carson winter films
are the mostest
boarding team along same record as the
Eagles disappointing you know what I
knew this was gonna happen
win when I should have predicted it when
everybody predicted the Eagles to win
the Superbowl when everybody that one
week in the offseason was like Eagles
are the deepest team in football and
Carson Wentz will be the MVP I have a
cough I'm not that sad you should be sad
with that cough we were all black today
yes to mourn to mourn to show our
respects when it was 10 nothing I texted
Athey and LuPone and my group chat and I
said this is a massacre
yeah and it all turned but then I went
28 to 14 no the first play of the game
I'm like yep here is I told you Ronald
Darby we're about to get this thing
rolling ten zip then at halftime I'm say
okay 21 14 a little bit closer than I
thought it should be but easily we'll
win this game by 10 at least because I
put money on the game Doug you did yes
her money hurt real money 100 bucks
Wow 100 bucks of my real hard own - 10 -
I want the Eagles to win the division I
have like multiple hundreds dollars of
them to win the division every team has
scored a bunch of points against this
team in our defense I've been playing
pretty dog gone good against Russell
Wilson and Tom Brady Doug Peterson told
WIP this morning he is disgusted mad and
angry my group chat like I'm sure many
Eagles group chats and by the way we're
gonna talk about the whole NFL but when
your team loses the Miami Dolphins it's
a big story and they were a Superbowl
favorite so bear with me we were going
who doesn't get on the flight home
there's a lot of people calling out how
we Roseman right now for the way this
team is constructed when you allow 37
points to just really lob balls to
Devante Parker and carries to Patrick
Laird yeah who looks like a grocery
store clerk works a lot of people are
going
this one's on Jim Schwartz you are
someone that knows this organization yes
dude does anyone lose their gig or does
anyone did anyone maybe not lose their
gig
week but at the end of the year this
game may have lost them their job well
we shoot even the great Dave fit special
teams coordinator I mean that little
trick play really how many trick plays
can teams run against the Eagles yeah
I'm with the trick played deal but I
bling and set this loss at the foot the
feet of Doug Peterson okay
I mean directly there and here's the
reason why it's your job as the head
coach to get your team to understand
Dallas just lost on Thursday we have a
chance at this point despite all the
crazy stuff that's going on despite the
injuries despite Carson Wentz not
playing up to this level despite all the
things that has happened on the
defensive line and so secondary
all the things that surrounded your team
people calling out the quarterback you
know inside the the locker room snitches
we still got a chance to control our own
destiny make it into the playoffs and it
all comes down to the next five weeks of
football so all that needs you guys to
do is dedicate yourself for five weeks
and that's going to help us and make us
force our way into the playoffs and when
we get it to the playoffs it's anybody's
game that's the conversation I want to
Doug Peterson to have this football team
this weekend looked unprepared didn't
look to seem that they wanted to execute
properly this team looked like you know
that special play that little trick
playing how about Doug's just says
listen this is a look that we weren't
anticipating we're just gonna call the
timeout and we're gonna get all our guys
on the sideline and say hey they may do
all these different things on this
playing let's make sure we just check
our guy how about we just call the
timeout there what's the harm because
what could have helped was you could
have saved the touchdown the harm you
had three to three timeouts so there's
no harm in doing that what's the harm in
adjusting during the game why Bill
Belichick is so special it's because he
doesn't it just just said a half time
here just in between series he pulled
his defense together last night even
though they didn't win and he has a
whole entire defense huddled around him
going over you do this and you do that
and when they do this we're gonna do
this than the other
yeah at one time did we see that from
Doug Peterson so much so
the Dolphins running offense is so
laughable they're terrible
that no one has had to put extra guys in
the box all year and yet I'm still
watching on multiple possessions
Devante Parker jumping over either
Ronald Darby or jaylen Mills one-on-one
hey guys the only offense they have how
about we double is a lob ball to Devante
let's take that away that one thing just
like that was the only thing I mean that
was responsible for like two of the
touchdowns and like 60% of their yard
like kiseki had a good game to the tight
end is such garbage well listen this is
what this is what Doug said he said in
his his the SEC is not he's not good no
but would with a no but that's what I'm
saying if I worry about the Eagles well
yeah but they were in position to make
the play they didn't execute they didn't
make the play so that tells me that
those guys aren't good enough that's why
you don't know I don't know what it is
about it but when you're watching like
I'm watching Patriots Texans yes and you
know how they put up the standings for
the playoff and it's got the division
leaders and it's got the two wildcards
and then it's got that one column that
says in the hunt I [ __ ] hate it yeah
there's something about looking up and
seeing the Eagles at five and seven the
myth with the Vikings and Seahawks
sitting there at nine and two and eight
and three and I'm looking at I'm going
we're not in the hunt
what hunt we've been hunted we are
currently on somebody's wall as a plaque
going the Miami Dolphins we beat the
Eagles we are the team right now where
people get like to get that win and like
they're saying right now that Brian
Flores is a coach of the Year candidate
uh-huh that's what beating us that's the
point of us playing right now we're
someone's homecoming game I'll bring the
Eagles in Oh coming home coming what get
it easy win there yeah weird that team
Carson wants to look better though he
looked better but there's Valjean back
out Sean and Carson seemed to have a
small connection there that that's a
Grail soon Aguilar had a great game he
did a great are great he had one play
that I thought was phenomenal they had
called back by penalties where he like
broke Lakes
six tackles had a big catch at the end
of the game where they were trying to
get it really when it comes down to this
is one of the 41 yards is what he had
that's not breaking for him I live in a
vacuum but we have to judge it by the
average on the NFL not just him know I
look a lot of this is I it's weird
because everyone's blaming how heroes
been right now but before the year all
they talked about was how the Eagles
were the deepest team in the NFL they
were mistaken and and that when you
looked at the wide receiving core with
Al Shean and DeSean and Nelson and Jaya
and Mack Hollins and JJ are Ithaca white
and now we just realized that all that
depth was nothing Oh from I said I bet
the Eagles to win I also bet JJ arteaga
Whiteside to get his first touchdown
hochi yeah you did
nice 800 bucks Wow rocket appreciate
that um I think we have some losses to
figure out but as an aside I don't I
don't know what to call this so I looked
it up it's an embarrassment is what it
is it's not embarrassment so the team's
three of the teams that won yesterday
mm-hmm
and I don't know who should be more
embarrassed actually I do
Miami beat Philly yes Cincinnati beat
the Jets the Jets should be very
embarrassed but at the same point I'm
more embarrassed because I should have
known that like if you're in the New
York Post on Monday for making out with
girls at bounce after you beat the
Raiders I should have right there but
like I'm betting Bengals moneyline yes
like I like that I'm embarrassed for
myself is that right yes the other one
though to me I believe is the most
embarrassing is that Washington went
into Carolina at home Carolina still
trying to get done up 14 nothing yeah
and they lose and props are guiderius
guys ditch the playbook no longer a
curse absolutely a bet that was this big
his first big game 10 carries a hundred
and twenty nine yards and a stiff arm
that was incredible
Brandon ball well but if you did a
moneyline parlay on Washington Miami and
Cincy wash in Miami both going off at
plus 425 yeah if you bet $100 you would
have made 60 $100
ah but here's the thing the first thing
I thought is well it used to be dolphin
tank but now they got three wins yes
it used to be Bengals tank they won
mm-hmm I don't know what its gonna be
it was getting is inching closer and
closer to being the Eagles tank we're
getting closer than that
I hope we're getting closer they play
let's go to the tank cuz I don't know
what it's gonna be called welcome back
to Bengal tank oh wait the Bengals won
this week let's call it red skin to know
they also won all right let's just go
back to the original dolphin - oh snap
they beat the Eagles lol crying laughing
face emoji
this week it's eagle Tang crab Wow first
into the eagle tank Lefko believes one
particular NFL head coach is like a
University of Arizona basketball recruit
well-paid but one and done ooh very good
joke right there I think it should be
giant tank the Giants are 2 in 10 and
they're bad they're bad bad bad they're
getting absolutely shellacked that's not
the coach I'm talking about I believe
that there is a coach of the NFL right
now that is one and done so you can look
at all of the the coaches that have
started their first year yeah it's
clearly not going to be Matt Lafleur
Brian Flores he'll keep his job they're
building clearly people are saying you'd
be up for Coach of the Year I if I was
gonna break it down for who it could be
it could be gay yeah it could be
kitchens but really I'm asking are you
buying it then I'll tell you who it is
afterwards him am i buying that the
coach should be one and done ask me any
questions with the record the team's
record uh I can't give you I give it
away of course you would yeah they have
more losses than they have wins yeah he
should be done he should be done okay
who do you think I'm talking about
kitchens or gates
oh you think they both should be done
either one I mean uh nothing here's the
thing Porsche interesting wasn't
expecting that
I was thinking kitchens but now you have
to talk about games well here's the
thing though first-year coaches have to
be able to develop the quarterback they
both have young quarterbacks you have to
be able to develop it I don't think
they're Freddie kitchens has shown
ability to develop Baker Mayfield or
control his football team or for that
matter control himself with the doggone
t-shirt you know I'm really upset people
did it upset you a lot that he wore a
Pittsburgh started at shirt that his
kids got him for his birthday and he
wore it to the movie it didn't upset me
what it did was it showed that he's
missing the point he's missing the point
that you don't need to give out bulletin
board material because your team isn't
that good you're missing the point that
your team has been in the media so much
preseason during the season and at this
point and they still can't dog on when
you're 5 and 7 so you're just missing
the point so not only can you not lead
your team but at this point you're not
helping your team either you're rarely
hurting your football team so let's give
him his hair let's compare this is
interesting anything about going this
way case and kitchens thus far mm-hmm
case the benefit that he has is that Sam
dard old missed five or six weeks yeah
and so he had a week of two weeks of
Luke Falk who was cut and then has not
been picked up which shows you the
quarterback play he was playing with his
signature win this year in my opinion
was the win over the Cowboys at home
he'll win 24 to 22 and he had a
three-game winning streak wins over the
Giants Washington and Oakland
other than that that loop that lost to
the Bengals is bad and they also did
lose in Miami which any team that loses
in Miami should just be relegated I
don't have necessarily a problem with
Adam GaSe I don't know that he's the guy
to make this team go to the next step
he hasn't shown me the same type of
things that we've seen from Freddie
kitchen right now Freddie kitchens
Freddie kitchens signature win was a win
at Baltimore in week four right win
doesn't even make sense how it happened
nope Nick Chubb ran wild it does make
sense how it happened Warren Sharpe
talked about all the time at that point
of the year Baltimore had a huge issue
guarding 11 personnel all Cleveland
played was 11 personnel it was a perfect
storm and even as we saw on Sunday you
can run on the Ravens yes and Nick Chubb
ran wild Baker made
kept his mistakes to a minimum ultimate
marketing had a fun much better since
then the Browns
also went on a three-game winning streak
with a win over the bills which is also
a great win a win over the Steelers
which was marred at the fact that miles
Garin spiked a helmet into the cranium
of Duke player Mason Rudolph and they
beat the Miami Dolphins losing to duck
Hodges and the Steelers
I guess my issue between the two you
think about the controversies they've
had Freddie kitchens has had the miles
Garrett controversy yeah the t-shirt
controversy hasn't been disciplined
again a lot of discipline most penalized
team in the NFL probably modern area of
the game probably the most turnovers
again discipline but but I think out of
the two I believe that the Browns
offense has felt more out of sorts in a
lot of their losses where I feel like
the Jets in this last stint Sam darn old
was healthy he was playing well what
putting up six points in Cincinnati is
deplorable it's awful but it I do feel
like kitchens has had a worse year that
what Keyes has gone through he had the
the Colette Co assembly controversy he's
had injured players complaining right
but also [ __ ] man
they're both bad kitchens feels
one-and-done to me this is why Freddie
kitchens is so bad because the
expectation you pay me you paid a bunch
of money to get Odell Beckham jr. on
your football team Jarvis Landry is a
Pro Bowl player Nick Chubb is gonna be a
Pro Bowler this year you have talent
Baker Mayfield first-round town it was
either he was 1st overall right oh yeah
so you you mean you have a bunch of
talent on that football team the defense
has some talent too there's a ward I
don't know what the heck happened it
just looks crazy out there at this point
you got a bunch of talent across the
board or your whole team the one thing
you had to do your job as a head coach
was to provide character and culture
character is gonna do make this locker
room come together your coach the same
type of thing and he hasn't provided
that and somebody you gotta say Baker
you know what this is what I need you to
say to the media because you're the face
of our franchise with me where we're
both the face of the franchise here's
the message we want to go
or with we're working hard we're working
out but all our heads down nose to the
ground and we're just gonna work
we ain't go talk to the meter we just
gonna grind and get better first game of
the seeds you get blown out by the the
Titans and the Titans would like listen
everybody who loves them they're the
best next best thing we wanted to go out
there and smack in their mouth and they
did that
yeah at that point you said your team
listen we ever handle easy games we got
a target on our back now it's time to
grind even harder that never happened
for this football team I have one way
that already kitchens can save his job
he can do something that hasn't been
done in Cleveland in 12 years and that's
get them to eight wins okay they're five
and seven right now yeah they have two
games against the Bengals one game
against the Cardinals and a game against
the Ravens so they would have to win
three if the Browns can beat the Bengals
twice and the Cardinals and they end the
season at eight and eight it will be the
most wins since 2007 under Romeo Crennel
if you can win three out of four that
also means that you would win six out of
your last eight what this happens in the
NFL and it's something that's frustrated
me forever remember that one year were
Adrienne Claiborne had six sacks in one
game and then the end of the year he had
ten sacks and was like wow what a great
year or jpp did it one year we had six
sacks against Winston justice on the
Eagles at the end of the year you're
like wow what a great year like so many
the eagle stacks this year I've come
against the dolphin and worse thing and
the worst teams if you end the year go
in six of eight and the Bengals defense
you should have some success against we
saw what the Rams did Arizona's defense
if and let's say that that Ravens game
maybe Ravens arrest in people in week 16
you give a little bit more fight as
possible we look at the end of year we
go oh they won 18 8 oh wow yeah I think
it's if you can survive that first Black
Monday where there's an average of six
seven eight coaches fired I think that
we'll look back and we'll forget all the
nonsense because we just look at the
record well I don't think I don't have
your owner that's not what you look at
you
I Jemmy Haslam's an idiot if your owner
you say well well why don't we get Odell
Beckham jr. we could've did this without
him why do we why are we you know still
dealing with some of the nonsense
the noise in is this - God is gonna take
us to the next level let's say he can
get to a 10-8 can he get us to ten and
six next year can you get us to twelve
and four that's a big question because
the same things keep happening in this
church thing that's to me that's huge
and it doesn't mean you know it is
innate to you to me it's big because it
also shows and I'm talking about you
have to use everything this is why is
big because you have to look at the the
total of everything yes the coach is out
there with that on really the coach not
Baker Mayfield not some of these young
players yeah the guy this is supposed to
set the example he's doing it
come on I know come on this is the guy
that's supposed to say hey everybody
come around me I'm going to show you the
way to victory that's the guy that's
doing that yeah that's the guy you got
to follow it is gonna be interesting
with Freddie kitchens going forward I
think also the one excuse I want to make
for Freddie kitchens is when have we
ever seen a team go out and sign a lot
of free agents and hire a new coach and
have success the first year very well
that's another one we're like we should
have seen it coming how many of these
dream team times do we need to see them
fall into the face where instead of
going big expectations we go oh no
they're gonna suck just know they're
gonna suck like we should have known it
takes time for them to come together I
think what you want to see out of teams
like that that are built this way is
some character some discipline you want
to see something that says you know this
gives me an idea that they're going to
be better next year yes if we haven't
seen that from this before Tim I just
realized that I picked who do I pick as
my wild cards in there I think one of
the wild cards I picked was the Steelers
I you don't listen I thought that the
Browns would come in into this game in
run all up and down where they started
off like Connor or nothing no juju they
started exactly like the Eagles duck is
at me you know the court it's at one
point in the second quarter of the
yardage was something like a hundred and
fifty two nine yeah for the Browns and
then duck hit a few deep
also James Washington but what duck is
doing is not losing and the Steelers
have a very dangerous defense they have
legitimate pass rushing threats and TJ
watt and bud Dupree minka in the back
has added a free safety that has allowed
the other Edmonds guy to play more in
the box the corners the fact that Joe
Hayden is the one that sealed the deal
with a pick the former Brown yes was Wow
perfect they have speed everywhere they
have really good leadership along the
defensive line I just don't want the
Steelers to make the playoffs because I
think they're really [ __ ] boring to
watch the team that I want to get in the
playoffs is the Titans
they have blow me away I want to
apologize its but what did I say to you
last week one of it was one of the
dolphin Bengal giant eagle tanks Derrick
Henry is gonna change the playoff
picture time of the year and that's what
he did comedy that loss for the Colts
epic he's huge
also listen I love Adam Vinatieri I love
him this isn't the Irishman it doesn't
have to go for three and a half hours
just to show the man the door that was
pop culture I like that I watched that
the other day I wash it and then I fell
asleep and then I finished watching it
and it was every morning course AZ movie
I've ever seen and I felt like it was
like a bunch of old guys making a movie
about hey we're really upset that our
kids don't visit us we hear stars
from our movie stars from the last 15 20
years all in one movie yeah and I would
say that if you've been wanting to see a
movie with De Niro and Pacino together
go watch [ __ ] heat it's 10 times
better
yes our own movie a long story I don't
know how her fields will get next tank
next into the Eagleton Lefko thinks one
current NFL contract will go down as the
worst free agent signing in history and
it's sad too because it's entirely
possible that Lefko has a framed photo
of this man right beside his bed at this
very moment you notice I'm making this
week's tank very simple it's like the
worst fridge in Saudi of all time
88 million dollars the 88 million dollar
one
they got benched yesterday mmm
Nikki Nikki Sixx oh my god Nick was
actually talked about Malcom Butler oh
you know here's a deal about Nick Foles
it's gonna go down as the worst I mean
you know Rob the worst I think Marone is
gonna lose his job I think that Coughlin
should be following suit yeah and I
think that I watched Gardner Minshew
come in yesterday and provide an instant
spark now granted he threw a pic inside
the end zone but he's a rookie that went
undrafted or later around so I'm not
expecting but Nick Foles went in there
and led three three announced and and
three interceptions yes and had a fumble
return for a touchdown
yes and in the last weeks we've been
talking about Jacksonville this is a
zine that I thought was going to win the
south because the talent they had on
defense didn't know they were gonna
trade Jalen Ramsay but in the last few
weeks they've lost to the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers by 17 the Titans by 22 the
colts by 20 and the texans by 23 mm-hmm
awful well here here's the thing about
Nick Foles and I think people in Philly
in particular think that he's he's a god
he's walking on water he's an angel
because he won the Superbowl flat seven
to 14 for 93 yards and an interception
Nick Foles has always been a backup
quarterback oh that's what he's been it
would be look at his numbers throughout
its career day they obviously speak to
that he's always been a backup
quarterback and he has the ability to
come in in a short span of time just
like a lot of other backups Gardner
Minshew was in the same way and add a
spark
right away but usually over the test of
time
16 games you start to see blemishes in
holes in his game and that's what we've
seen every time he's become the starter
holes in his game he happened in Philly
last year holes in his game it happened
when he went out to st. Louis hoes in
his game
it happened in Jacksonville when he came
back from injury holes in his game he's
in some limited play listen I can't
bring him from taking the money take the
dog or money absolutely I blame the
Jacksonville Jaguars for thinking that
this guy was gonna come in and win games
for you what did you see I thought he
was no well then you weren't being
honest with yourself you were drinking
the kool-aid from the doggone superb how
could I not what do you mean how could
you not did he look like a franchise
saver how much money do you think Nick
Foles has made in his career he's played
eight seasons he's played five with the
Eagles one with the Rams one with the
other Rams when they moved one with the
Chiefs and one with the Jaguars 150 150
million no he's made 62 million but he
just said here 288 million not alter
some of that's to be owed to him so if
he finishes this contract he ends at
about a hundred and twenty okay it's
close which is incredible well you got
how much did he get paid last year he
got paid last year in Philly is it back
at 12 millions well a lot of incentives
listen I said this about the Eagles last
year that I wanted them to keep nick
foles
and pay him 15 million and named Carson
Wentz the starter and named Nick Foles
the closer and what you do is you let
Carson play the first 14 games and then
you bring in foals for the playoffs I
thought it was genius yeah because I
think Nick is great when he comes in
when everything's falling apart that's
right because Nick's specialty is not
the first ten plays of the game it's
when everything is going to [ __ ] and
someone's got a lob up a beautiful 50/50
ball yeah and that's what he does yeah
and does a great job at it he is the
second-string guy and everybody loves
the second-string quarterback until they
become the starter and separately they
become the guy that you
to depend on all the time and then you
realize you know what he's not that good
he's not as good as I thought he was
that's Nick Foles and I love Nick Foles
great guy he's just not as good enough
to be a starter in the NFL it's wild all
right let's go back to Eagleton and
finally into the ego tag left I was not
looking for an investment he's looking
for forgiveness and can Brian Westbrook
find it in his heart to podcast partners
with a disagreement but a shared love of
football
this Christmas NFL stands for national
friendship league
it's the apology rated pg-13 you're
right because I'm a curse I won't
apologize two notches you yeah but to
the entire city of Houston
you should I have been saying all year
long that they will be a team of
regression mm-hmm
I laughed in your face we know you said
they were gonna win the division right
here in my face I laughed in your face
I even think two weeks ago that you said
that Texans were gonna beat the Patriots
horrible things that you've done to me I
think that I owe you a money but I don't
owe you a money because you owed me a
money if you like you owe me lots of
money I do not but I want to apologize
you were right I was wrong
that's it is that it yeah I feel like it
was it was insincere it was just kind of
like yeah you're just doing it just
because I want a different apology go
that's where you're right and I was
wrong okay that feels better because I
know that it hurts you I know that hurts
you deep down on the inside like you may
be putting on this little message that
hurts you it's not just cuz you said it
it's because it's Bill O'Brien it's
Romeo Crennel it's like there's no one
that I like Bill O'Brien looks like a
gas station owner that just I do it my
way don't tell me what to do a kid
listen I do let it let it on premium
that's how I've always done it and so
like I look at Bill O'Brien and I go
here comes Bill Belichick
and and Bill O'Brien's acting as GM and
he's just trading for anybody and he's
giving oh he's mortgaging the future and
I don't even and and really everything
has broken his way everything Nick Foles
gets hurt and ends up being a second dog
crap Andrew Luck goes down right you
know the Indianapolis Colts in their
game yesterday their top five weapons
that they came into the season with none
of them played at wide receiver Parris
Campbell like you forget Devin Funchess
and t-white Hilton yeah they were Eric
Ebron he's not out there and then like
the biggest threat to the Texans right
now is Ryan Tannehill that's right
that's crazy
why not let me what the Texans did to
the Patriots on Sunday night was
beautiful mm-hmm they were ready for
everything Patriots did a surprise zone
can't do that against the Sean no Sean
it's too smart yeah
picked that bad boy apart oh you're
gonna double Hopkins okay guess what we
got well then I get to use Kenny Stills
man oh man also Romeo Crennel doing what
Belichick does double-teaming Edelman
allowing you to run on him because
whatever will stop it eventually and
forcing you to beat forcing you to beat
him with Jacoby Meyers and Matt Lacoste
it was a perk you know damn well it's
over the entire run is over I can't
believe it after so many incredible
seasons I just can't believe that
Netflix would cancel Bojack horseman do
you think I was talking about the
Patriots dynasty being over not a chance
in New York my dude that's West Roxbury
for not a chance in hell Jets suck
Yankees suck in fact me and my buddies
are over here slam and celebratory
triple-deckers with crispy onions at the
Wahlberg is that they hang him shipyard
baby Belichick has planned this one to
perfection bill O'Brien's now a lock to
make the playoffs which is only good
news for oh the entire AFC every defense
we face for the rest of the air is gonna
send some friggin candy godness to god
Edelman endorsed ed and
while the friggin Ravens are like a mall
Santa peeking in early December and then
having to face a line of disappointed
children come January when they found
out their wishes did not come true oh
shut up we're tending to we're gonna get
a first round bye and if you were gonna
name a dude on another team who's
actually a mole working for the good
people of the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts to help the Patriots in
the second round of the playoffs
wouldn't his name kind of definitely be
Sean McDermott we're fine
chase vinovich and gunner Olszewski are
the same person there I said it
pat pat out Pat always confident listen
I think the Patriots they have four
games left two of them are very tough
for them who we got so you have the
Chiefs you got the bangles easy game you
got the bills and then the Dolphins man
so the Chiefs in the bills
obviously the Chiefs we all know passion
for home was throwing the ball all over
the place but the ski the Chiefs here
but the bills are the team that played
the toughest all season long
that always give them problem do you
know that if the bills went out they
were in the AFC East boom ain't gonna
buy and for the first time in the last
25 years can't even imagine boom I don't
want to gloss over the Texans though
okay you shouldn't because there are a
few teams in this league that you can be
better than in all three phases and you
can still lose to the Texans are one of
those teams sorry Texans Chiefs Seahawks
Packers the teams with and the Ravens
teams with a quarterback that can just
do things that you can't stop there was
a sequence last night or Sunday night
that caught my attention
Watson drops back there was a 30-plus
yard touchdown to will fuller back in
the end zone
they're going up to three scores holy
crap challenged taken back the very next
play Kenny Stills deep touched him this
is the boogeymen this is the Patriots
defense and what's so wild is I have
[ __ ] on Bill O'Brien so many times but
to go out and get Laremy Tunsil yeah to
go out and get stills
to go out and get Vernon Hargreaves who
had a very big game last night the pass
rusher they traded to the Seahawks that
they traded cloudy the Seahawks the guy
they got back Martin I mean Cris
Collinsworth couldn't shut up about him
and all I could think about was the
Texans are winning a regular season game
that's gonna lock Bill O'Brien in as the
head coach GM because it came out on
Sunday morning the Texans might not hire
a GM next year and the guy they were
gonna hire was Nick kesariya from the
Patriots I I know Pat Pat's joking I'm
kind of not I have always believed that
Bill Belichick sometimes perfectly's
Luke purposefully loses to his former
assistants to keep them in positions so
that he can use them at later times they
were gonna sue the Texans Bob Graff was
gonna sue the Texas now Belichick gets
to keep Nick Caesarea locked away in a
closet scouting out the gun Earl chefs
keys of the world and if they do face
the Texans in the playoffs they're gonna
beat the crap out of them
you think so I think that Texans are a
very good team at home okay
I could go with that I do not see them
going into Foxborough and winning now
the Texans are eight and four but let me
just say cuz I keep qualifying
everything congratulations Houston
you're a very good team with an
incredible quarterback and I have talked
way too much trash about Bill O'Brien
but now I have to cough because clearly
I don't mean it well this is what we saw
in the game you have the worst coffee in
America those we saw in the game we saw
the the Patriots at dominate time of
possession yep total yards obviously
Russia yeah yeah it's all deceiving yeah
yeah but what we also saw was the
Houston Texans walk in was it their
secondary or linebackers walked in like
listen wearing SWAT team uniforms I
would never believe it uh you know this
is what I like and nothing I'll bring it
back from the Baltimore game before the
Baltimore Patriots game I said the rape
aren't scared by the Patriots in a big
part of the Patriot lore is when you
walk into Foxborough if you play these
guys you see Bill Belichick and Tom
Brady walking into your stadium there's
a little bit of fear what's the
commonality between both of those teams
both of those games were in Baltimore
and huge in the road absolutely and that
what Patriots will still somehow end up
with with a van this this game last
night I thought was important because
you had a team with three very good
receivers one one of them wishes elite
Hopkins and you can't you don't as good
as a patriot secondary is they don't
have three guys no they just don't
McChord he was out too they don't have
three guys to handle three different
guys and I'll tell you this coming into
the game I thought that Houston would
run the ball a little bit more than they
did because I think Carlos Hyde has been
playing well also yeah and he only I
don't think you only got a handful of
maybe 10 12 carries and so III still
think they have some more options there
but anytime you have deshaun Watson a
new team who can be Superman he thinks
is going to give his guys opportunities
down the field which I kind of we kind
of glossed over it Ryan Fitzpatrick
that's what he did to his guys you throw
it up and give us guys just go be an
athlete go figure it out this shot is up
there in the top three for most
beautiful deep ball no doubt about it no
doubt so they and their their season
they're 10 they're eight and four they
play the Titans twice weeks 15 and 17
which is gonna be I mean that's fighting
it out now for the AFC South what the
Titans going out there and beating the
Colts a game against the Broncos at home
they should win yeah Broncos lock drew
lock I thought had some good moments I
thought I've had a lot of Broncos fans
and my mentions talking about how great
he was
Cortland Sutton is a phenomenal wide
receiver he cleared that one catchy at
was incredible that p.i at the end of
the game was absolute [ __ ] but I
don't give the Chargers any benefit of
the doubt they're the worst run
organization in the NFL they don't
understand analytics they're guessing
all the time Philip Rivers has been done
for two years no over it's over Philip
Rivers enjoys throwing balls in the dirt
more than he enjoys completing path I
thought Phillip Rivers and the charges
had a chance last year last year
squandered it in now that when I saw
that they had to go to Foxborough the
playoffs I said oh they don't have a
chance because they don't even know what
they're like we're gonna run the same
thing that we ran against the Ravens
against the Patriots but if the Texans
run the table and they go twelve and
four it's a lot of teams that need to
run the table but the biggest thing that
happened yesterday is my prediction is
now one step closer to being right and
what was that prediction that the
Baltimore Ravens will be the number one
seed in the AFC and I said it in [ __ ]
August well I think that you mean you
saw something that no one else saw and
it was a development that a quarterback
getting much much better yesterday he
didn't have a very good passing day it
was a rainy day look Joel oh look
everybody - that's right but that was
undoubtedly two of the top four teams in
the sport two of the top six teams in
the sport I believe we have a six I
believe it is the Ravens Niners and
Patriots seven chief Saints oh I didn't
maybe it's Green Bay there's a Seahawks
but I feel like people on the Vikings I
keep trying to tell people I wouldn't
sleep on if I can see there don't sleep
on them I hope they get how did they
lose tonight by the way hope you endured
hits too but the the Ravens Niners two
of the top I would say they're two of
the top four teams on the sport I don't
know who the other two teams are but
they're definitely the elite of the
elite and to watch them exchange body
blows there were times where I thought
the Ravens are gonna run away with this
right there was a time where the Niners
looked like they kind of had the lead
yeah most hurt that the Niners whoever
and healthy running back is they're able
to get them off that's Kyle Shanahan's
office inseparable it's amazing those
guys are shot out of a cannon all of
them are the same dude Coleman most dirt
Breda when they're all one-step runners
they all are like I'm fast and I miss a
wide open hole and I'm downfield and the
Niners are a good matchup for the Ravens
because the Ravens can be run on and the
Niners will just stretch outside
decide and wait for you to commit and go
up the field Jimmy Garoppolo I thought
played okay mm-hmm
the the the the benefit of the doubt
that I give to Jimmy Garoppolo compared
to all these other average quarterbacks
is that Jimmy doesn't seem the moment
never seems big for him even when he's
under pressure he has a coolness to him
that a lot of other guys don't show and
that's why I have respect for Jimmy but
you watch that game Ravens Niners did
you come away even more impressed with
the Ravens we I felt like I heard a lot
of below Vader's and prognosticators
talking about how they actually left the
game impressed with the Niners I heard a
lot of people saying that they didn't
think the Niners were for real I don't
know what the hell they were paying
attention to you could say that the
first six games of the season but the
last riders have been for real for like
the last six I don't get it
they look but what was your big takeaway
from that game I think my big takeaway
from that game was there's no team that
I'm gonna be able to keep up with what
the Ravens are doing offensive ly
because if any team that had the ability
to do it
it was the Niners they're right you did
feel like the Niners were trying to keep
up with the Ravens I did feel like the
pace of the game they were built to be
able to stop it they can't and I and I
think they had one of the best inside
backs in the game
Lauren Werner yeah Warren I think he's
just a baller period I was very confused
at the amount of times that Lamar
Jackson kept the ball and that there was
no one on backside that's my point I
didn't understand if if I'm going into a
game especially with that type of
defense I'm gonna say okay this is what
I'm gonna do
I'm not respecting the handoff if if
Maura Ingram has I feel also is cracking
down on Ingram the entire that's my
point if Mark Ingram has 200 yards cool
we can't allow Lamarck Jackson have 200
yards that's the one quite the person we
can't fill out a due to prop bets that I
should have been betting every week and
they keep going up is Lamar Jackson
rushing yards and Derrick Henry rushing
yards Lamar Jackson I think time of year
a hundred yards and it was at like 80
I've never seen a quarterback up the
prop bat was 80 but yeah but at the same
point if you let Mark Ingram keep going
the play-action pass I don't know but is
devastating so I think you can rally
around trying to stop the running back
it's devastating when when Lamar Jackson
makes guys missing a hole is this like a
Steph Curry you walk past half court in
two to three I've never seen a margin I
think it stopped on a third or fourth
and short
I just haven't here is the one concern I
do have for Lamar Jackson the last two
weeks I feel like he's been getting hit
in weird places
he's second so he got hit in the last
game more interview also that rip fumble
was incredible but you're right we had
it's kind of Lamar I don't I didn't
really see it as much two weeks ago the
Niners hit him yeah
the last two weeks in my mind he got hit
someone some of them are right on the
edge of being out of bounds where he's
kind of slowing up thinking no one's
gonna touch him he's getting smacked I
hate to see that
but he's getting hit in different ways
now that's a concern for me it's been a
should be a concern for John Harbaugh as
well so the Ravens just left a six-game
stretch that I remember us talking about
man if they go 500 they should be happy
mm-hmm the Seahawks at the peak of their
power
the Patriots we said oh they're gonna go
one against the Bengals the Texans the
Rams the Niners not only do they not go
three and three
they don't go four and one for and two
they don't go 501 they go six and OH and
they win those games by a combined point
differential of 143 let's take a look at
what the Ravens have done the last six
weeks
they beat the Seahawks by 14 the
Patriots by 17 the bengals by 36 that
texans team that just beat the Patriots
they beat by 34 yeah they beat the Rams
by 39 and the Niners by 3 143 impressive
that they've been impressive you got to
give a little credit because when you're
playing against the Niners you got a
deal with George Kittel and I know he
spent a lot of time blocking and that
grunt game got off but check Chuck Clark
the safety for the Ravens forced the
fumble on Jimmy G and he was his job was
a slow
down and stop George kill just a bit two
catches for George kiddo
that's impressive that's great work the
one question i think pat pat might have
raised this question do you think that
he's the Ravens as a team are peaking a
little bit too early we've been we've
been saying that for a little bit I
think that well are they continue to get
better you know that this sport really
comes down to availability and right now
what's incredible to me is they're
playing that d-line and they lost their
starting center for the year last week
right and I didn't see them really miss
a beat and the the if they can maintain
their offensive line they can maintain
their skill players they're in a
position where if they lose a tight end
they still have three more yes it always
comes down to injuries at this point of
the year and so the way they're
constituted I think they'll be fine now
they're going to face down the stretch
they now go to at Buffalo okay which is
now turned into like home-field
advantage
I mean if Buffalo wins that game and
makes the Ravens go to ten and three
Buffalo will then be ten and three that
would be insane well here's the thing
though and I know is and in Buffalo but
if you say okay 49ers defense in which
you can't you do against that defense
compared to Buffalo's defense in Buffalo
is a good defense they're not on the
same low as if not at all not in I have
to be confident if I'm on the Ravens to
say you know we just beat the best
defense in football now let's go up
there and beat up on a good defense huh
fellow's got an extra week extra few
days because it's not about it's not
well you play against them all Lamar
it's not about an extra week because you
could game plan it and he puts you in a
bind and that's not a question
what the heck there are you seen and are
you fast enough to get there I think
that the Ravens are built in a way in
which it's sound like the Rams last year
where we were kind of like who's gonna
figure out this often yeah the Ravens
offense is simple yeah you know it yeah
you know who's likely gonna have the
ball I think the Ravens success going
forward will come down to the four or
five deep balls that Lamar throws every
game yeah does he complete them
he hit the one touchdown to Mark Andrews
he had another one where they didn't
call the pass interference it was
little bit questionable and that's why
it was a tough game to throw in you also
look at the next few weeks at Buffalo
it's gonna be cold home against the Jets
it will likely be cold at Cleveland
mistake by the lake a lot of wind then
home against Pittsburgh they need to buy
but Baltimore is a team that it's okay
if it gets cold we will run 40 times
against you absolutely and I I think on
Sunday by beating the Niners I am my
opinion John Harbaugh one coach of the
year because in my opinion it was
between John Harbaugh and Kyle Shanahan
and for them to go out on Sunday to milk
the last six minutes of the clock to
have your Hall of Fame kicker Justin
Tucker punch it through but to really
set the tone for the entire game I want
to give the coach of the year to John
Harbaugh not just for the fact that he
has him at ten and two and number one in
the AFC and having shellacked the
Patriots the seahawks the Texans the
Rams and beat the Niners for me it's
also the fact that what they did in the
off season what John Harbaugh has
instituted in Baltimore after there were
thoughts that he might get fired last
year absolutely John Harbaugh to me as a
coach of the year I can go there I love
John Harbaugh I love John Hart bulb
because he's obviously showing
confidence in Lamar Jackson and his
ability to do that when no one else
would have designed this type of offense
around him they would have figured out
try to be a pocket passer things like
that I love that but as a coach when you
start thinking of situational football
there's nothing like John Harbaugh I
just remember being in special teams
meetings he he'd be like well it's
working - on the 40 you know we have a
better percentage of this is this is 13
years ago but before analytics even came
into play we have a better percentage of
success if we do these things you could
tell his team understands that yeah you
could tell that he preaches that into
his team and I love the way that he's
got his team to rally around the
quarterback they believe in him a young
kid they believe in them they want him
to win and they built a team
specifically for this type of
quarterback run the football stop the
run they don't do a great job of
stopping a run
but they are physical enough in the end
in their game plan defensively to slow a
team down so that now you could grind
the ball out the offensive side of the
ball I've been impressed by Harbaugh I I
certainly can make the argument for Kyle
Shanahan yeah and what they've been able
to do because that team you can make an
argument for Bill Belichick every year
every year yeah yeah yeah but but Kyle
Shanahan when you look at that team
before the season no one really knew
what the heck Jimmy G was he did okay
but everyone's like okay we'll see what
what happens between last year this year
and see how Defence's adjust to him but
that office still was making ways for me
the top four seeds for coach of the year
in my opinion I'm not gonna say Zimmer
I'm not gonna say Pete Carroll I think
that's been a lot of Rus for me the top
for Coach of the Year candidates are
horrible Shanahan McDermott and Payton
Sean Payton has the Saints at ten and
two winning sick five games with Teddy
Bridgewater and thinking about if I told
you before the year they wouldn't have
Drew Brees for five games you'd say they
take a step I said they were done yes I
said actually the Buffalo Bills at nine
and three talk about building around
another sophomore quarterback if Lamar
wasn't doing what he's doing right now
we talked about Josh Allen in that
season Kyle Shanahan and and how he's
turned this franchise in three years
into a behemoth but the reason I give it
to Harbaugh is every single week I feel
like he has the coaching edge and he out
coach Kyle Shanahan this past week it
was it was nail-biter that's why I'm
going with Harbaugh I like Harbaugh I
like the choice I think that's a great
choice I I wouldn't argue with that I
could all change we have four more weeks
left well I mean you got to look at the
total the total season me but listen
look at how their team is playing look
how they face some adversity early on
they came back and still continued to
play well yeah they beat the teams that
no one thought they had a chance of
beating Texas blew him out
they beat the 49ers last week this past
weekend and they beat the Patriots
that's huge so there were two blowouts
last this past Sunday that we did not
talk about really at length Green Bay
over the Giants and Chiefs over the
Raiders
yeah Green Bay over the Giants I don't
know if I'm buying Green Bay as a real
real contender I there's a lot of things
that they do when you have Aaron Rodgers
I never want to doubt it getting Devante
Parker Davante Adams back being healthy
is good but when you really look back at
a lot of their wins so you know their
big win was at Kansas City again
Matt Moore was playing they get
shellacked by San Francisco they beat
Chicago to start the year the win over
Minnesota looks good now but Denver
Dallas you know we kind of see what
Dallas is I don't really see a lot of
the big heavyweights I don't and when I
look at the rest of their schedule
Washington should be a win Chicago
should be a win then at Minnesota at
Detroit I just if Green Bay gets into
the playoffs and is facing a New Orleans
or a San Francisco I just don't see them
beating them well you got to imagine
this and this is why I like the game for
Green Bay yesterday
cold rainy snowy mix flurries yes field
looks crazy
that's a playoff game in Lambeau I know
then that's why that's why it's so hard
to talk about these matchups because if
the Saints lose to the Ravens next week
if they'll have to go to Lambeau right
that's not good for the thing it's very
interesting so there's so many top
seedings up for grabs usually I feel
like there's one team that runs away
with it in the NFC and then the Patriots
in the AFC but I also know that it's
been historic in terms of elimination so
in New Orleans is in there the NFC South
champion and they have owned that
division the teams that have been
eliminated
Cincinnati Detroit Atlanta Giants Miami
Arizona 26 teams in playoff can in
contention after week 13 is the fewest
since 2014 and you have to go back to
2005 for fewer so we've eliminated
eliminated a lot of the weakness but in
the NFC it is so top-heavy Minnesota
could get a Buy and they're a wild-card
team Seattle if new or if if they beat
San Francisco in week 17 could go from a
while
card seed to the number one seed in the
NFC that's right the playoff seeding is
all over the place and I just don't
think Green Bay is up there with it it's
also pretty cool that it's gonna go to
the last week of the season with the
fact that San Francisco's play in
Seattle week 17 is that's why they have
those division games at the last week
which is pretty cool
the other game though Chiefs blowout the
Raiders easy if you listen to the warren
sharp podcast i went on a whole rant
about how there's no better time to bet
against derek carr than in the cold
against Kansas City he is now Owen six
two interceptions one of them being a
pick six I also think that they had a
wild extra point return for a two-point
conversion that hit the over for some
people I didn't get to watch it they
felt the need to switch over to Denver
chargers no offense there are two teams
that are like three and four wins it's
Philip Rivers and like I'm over the
Three Stooges of watching Philip Rivers
at the end of games with two minutes
left he's gonna throw a pick or do
something dumb I don't need to see it
but the Chiefs the Chiefs showed us
something interesting a 31-point win
with Patrick mahomes only throwing for a
hundred and seventy-five yards and your
leading rusher being Darwin Thompson for
44 what they did get yesterday was three
turnover pressure and turnover yeah the
Kansas City Chiefs defense Loki is up
there right now in terms of past offense
now you could do what Josh Jacobs did
and rush for over a hundred yards in the
first half because that's what the
Chiefs will allow you but in terms of
passing yards per game they're at 16th
or right in the middle of the pack
that's not bad from where they started
at cuz I'm saying beat up
you got Tyrann Mathieu back there ball
Hawken yep this kid won Thornhill the
one that the returned they got some
young corners that are pretty good Chris
Jones is healthy D Ford will be back I I
look at the Chiefs and I go now that's a
team then a Vega in the playoffs can
scare anybody do you know that
mahomes Kelsey and tire
he'll have all only played together
three games this year yeah we haven't
even seen the clicks the one thing I'm
wondering about the Chiefs can they ever
get a consistent run game oh that's the
question can they stop the run which i
think is i don't think so i don't think
they can do that I think they're kind of
okay with letting it happen I think
they're passing defense has been better
because of the defensive line has gotten
a little bit healthier but when you had
that offense it puts so much pressure on
the opposing offense right and so
usually we say orphans versus defense
cuts their offense puts so much pressure
on their opposing offense that you have
to score touchdowns every time you have
the ball now the play Carter's like okay
I got to draw up some crazy crap just to
be able to score because if we don't
score we can't keep up with this team
Oakland Raiders three terminals
turnovers we talked about that 12 dogs
on penalties you can't wait I don't care
who you are I don't care who you have in
your team but whether you have Derek
Carr whether you have Brett Favre you
can't win
can't win football that way in
discipline is something that Jon Gruden
preaches all the time 12 penalties
jumped out at me as I'm looking at their
possessions interception first one to
fumble punt turnover on downs
interception missed field goal punt you
can't win that way and that's against
the Chiefs defense that is average at
best the Oakland Raiders have a worse
point differential than the Jacksonville
Jaguars the Oakland Raiders have a worse
point differential than the New York
Jets the Oakland Raiders are six and six
and have been outscored in their games
by 87 points you don't see that that's
not something you see this is a team
that I think was a little bit
overinflated and I think we got on the
train and I understand I'm thrown the
Train but they I love max Crosby I love
that kid he's a great pass rusher
they've had a ton of injuries their
secondary stinks and they really know
how many weapons over there Darren
Waller their artena Josh they got a
bunch of 13 this building this is even
if they end their season at eight Nate
that's a great season for them
especially with all the Antonio Brown
offensive scoring the season for them
here's the thing about the Chiefs Abrams
have been hurt all season do you think
the Chiefs
this Sunday can go into New England
and beat the Patriots Tom Brady came out
and said we're not two and ten where ten
and two which means that Tom Brady which
he always does
goes from we're not that good to stop
talking crap about that about us were
really good which is the worst time to
play the Patriots Patriots off of a loss
because if they beat the Patriots tell
me if they can win these games home
against the Broncos yes at the Bears yes
home against the Chargers yes okay
that's three if they beat the Patriots
they go to twelve and four it makes it
much more interesting bills could lose
another game bills are playing the
Ravens if the Chiefs get some home field
that's different so here's a Patriots
game in a nutshell
oh I'm so good in my mind I think at
this point the Patriots have won with 21
straight at home this is hard to beat at
home it's hard to beat to go into
Foxborough whether I have heard from so
many players that it's such an
intimidating place to play absolutely
again I told you there are teams that
welcome to the field and they see Bill
Belichick on the other sideline like up
we can't win it it's also apparently the
way the Patriots have the stadium set up
with the Super Bowl banners with them
and it's the it's constantly reminding
you of how unstoppable they are that it
has to get into your psyche always all
of those things play a part into it all
every last one of those things play a
part into it and then you get into the
game and now you have to be you can't
make a mistake because if you make a
mistake they capitalize on every mistake
and you're going to the game you say
well you know what yes so you're not
running fast you're making machine
you're trying to figure out you're not
you're thinking that's the one thing you
can't do that's the one thing that the
Ravens made the Patriots do they made
them think to try to figure out where
the ball is going Lamar doesn't think
he's just win he just wins then he just
runs and so that's it's gonna be it's
gonna be interesting I never asked you
this before but before we go there let
me think about this for the chunka the
Patriots take away your best player
right do what you do best so it's a
great Tyree kill or Kelsey
I would probably say Tyriq so okay again
the number is three you have three
players that you can you can't take away
that's the same type of Tyreke Kelsey
and then they need Sammy they if those
guys could have a good game yeah then
they can win if one of those running
backs
I feel like LeSean McCoy is good for
like a half a quarter every I think
LeSean McCoy is resting his legs and
Lulu else that's what I think I think
Andy is saying his legs are dead right
now we're resting them because we're
gonna need to be able to run the
football use his ability out of the
backfield of the Hat
that's what I think do you got a source
on that it's good feeling that have oh I
love that that sounds great I think
that's great
planning what what was the cause you're
gonna need what was the state I never
asked you support the Stadion stadium
opener game against the Bucks when Jo Jo
Vicious caught that crazy gate touchdown
do you remember that night the first
game and in the link first game in the
link yeah and so we had played them in
an NFC championship game they won the
serve in the last game in the vet so we
were a pissed-off dog it's a story that
is in this podcast a lot because I snuck
into that game with my dad my dad was
cleaning ice machines in refrigeration
at the stadium and we said that there
was some mess ups and ice machines so we
had to get in there and we stood on
those steps right under where rocky kid
yeah the reason I had a lot of stuff at
the podcast is that was Sims his first
game as a pro he was a rookie because
they just wanted he got drafted for that
he was on the sidelines did you have a
good game that game I had a decent game
a big big kickoff return to start the
game had a decent game I feel like the
amount of times that you guys had big
kick returns that like remember the game
the year before against the Bucs yeah
big kick return by Brian Mitchell yeah
and then do Staley like 30-yard
touchdown right I thought it was over
yeah I mean we lost that game - pretty
sure we lost the first game in the vet
it's kind of sucks - the same well the
vet that was like the link when I was
there that was the game it sucked
it was the Joe Joe is just pop up to
himself get preciate you bring that up
the heartbreak that I just wasn't sure
if you'd had in my rookie year and my
second I appreciate that
the herky ear was
the Rams no no my Ricky here was the dog
going the Bucks
when we'd the last game in a vet house
my rookie year man
the Rams lost the NFC Championship game
you were not on the team yet that was
luck also got hurt in that game and they
stopped running the football he was
having a great game they stopped running
the football because he got hurt it was
also the Freddie Mitchell across the was
pretty much all that team huge before
you Freddie Mitchell across the middle
and aeneas Williams kind of pass
interference but they didn't call it and
aeneas Williams but after that what do
they do
Leo Shepherd Sheldon Brown Michael Lewis
Brian Westbrook
Beth Eve of draft ever Todd Harriman's
no he was a couple years pride in your
draft he was part of the Brent Celek
Todd arrogance Trent kold-draft another
up there good draft good draft not as
good as the other one he goes last year
not a good draft they're still trying to
figure things out craft wise but they're
dead we've we played them the rest so if
he heals come back they are there they
will now be known after everyone is the
zombie Eagles know it came as zombie
apocalypse it'll be a miracle if they
come back yeah but it's but they're dead
they're dead so far if they come back
there'll be a miracle stop it
if they come back play the music because
they're dead disappointing death all
black like I said you bit out of Miami
to retire that's what they did for Brian
what you asked you asked Greg Jennings
why do patinas go to Miami to lose he
told you I don't think they party but
again that thought process you think in
Miami easy win fun in the Sun you come
flat fun and you're done
what are you done I did see a t-shirt in
Walmart store that said Randall
Cunningham is the Rocket Man what are
you saying are you kidding me ya gotta
get this [ __ ] copyrighted bro hey for
Brian Westbrook the rock you made the
real the real rocking man on the lef koe
man we are not going to have a show on
Wednesday my ass has to be in Atlanta
but we will be back on Thursday Friday
for we don't have a pockets come on this
Thursday with Brian we do it the war and
sharp podcast so I will see you next
week sweet brother travel safely born
yeah this and make sure enjoy yourself
in the lab I will okay
[Music]